家月と言えばうそ
お花見俺はまだこのシーズンに入ってからお花火をしていない
数えてする人もこっちくれスペインをなんかいい感じの人数でお花見をするとすれば
夜中にやるしかないところがもっと上げますぜひで今日は今から両団体の12時から僕
が今からツイッターとかで宣伝します今からお話3しますみなさん良かったらぜひ高に
聞いてくださいねという形で順で果たして何
んでしたが僕のお花見に来てくれるかちょっと実験をしてみ行ったりと絶景をしたいと
思いますなに行くともうまくあ難しい12時からで寝ちゃうよ店ではの
そう店で18歳以上人はね少なくなるとだか実際のところた笑ちょっとわかんないんで
ドーン
1時間で所や難しいねあと俺の予想は
ん
ブーバーして12時から1時のこのシーンあー時間に何人ぬーんっ
トゥデイ
me
ムーディーし
あと8分ぐですねずーっとずん子からつぶやくことにしましょう
ok
桜のた肉声
ブルーせる2はメッサー人か
てるじゃないですかあと3分後でちゃんと写真も載せておいたのでここにみんなが1
時間の間に何これるか
はい呟きましたあ
スタートアーサー何人来るけどねここから我々もちょっとずつか落ち着こう
腹減ったんねそれの面積
まだ誰も来ませんっ
次も俺だ爪しかに行かないなーっ
ただいま24:10でさせが20分じゃ人は来ない必要
10分経過してもただいま0人ですあるものとか買おうと思ったんですけど時間が
なかったんで
またきっと2人で pop してます
始めファーレっねちょっとこれを10年近くも一緒に行きました
ねえ
食べ物も何もないんですえええええ50過ぎ終わると
5あれまあツイッター見て
ちょっとこれいいですかあっ本当にできましたぁーっアタックをし
ん
プチパーティ
すごいやばいすごいです誰だよあっ
ぐっの戻し金を受けません
ねハッハイって話使って方が良いよ
こんばんはー
3人目てで a こんばんは
遊んですか
本当ですか若第1項うーん
女見てるよ
ああああああ
re
殺人鬼ずれました
ごーっん
ん
投票せよ
それは食べ物がえっと炭酸水3本とまかないしかないよ
26分で10人集まっていくございましたありがとうございます
前作アップまったねー
ブーブー客をしますウードゥーよ
ございません
えっ12:46残り14分で80人が祈っています
1時まで何人が行くのでしょうか
ございました
いいいいいい
なんで正木これやばいジョイ
はいという気で一時になりました
1時間でちょっと何人集まったかちょっと
数えていこうと思います
三橋を放っていた
一つです
me
じゃあ俺を可決鉄球
100ずう111 a 8だけだと1時間を学びをしいただくと
111人当てはまることが分かりました
びっくり仰天
ん
uh
voodoo
sen
ございません